- Bentornati a Capire
l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono
il Direttore Tecnico per IBM Quantum Education.
Questa è la quarta lezione della serie ed è l'ultima
lezione della prima unità della serie sulle basi
dell'informazione quantistica.
Finora abbiamo parlato di
come funziona l'informazione quantistica per sistemi sia singoli che multipli, abbiamo esaminato il
modello a quantum circuit,
e abbiamo osservato alcune
limitazioni fondamentali dell'informazione quantistica.
Lungo il percorso abbiamo
incontrato alcuni importanti concetti matematici
tra cui i prodotti tensoriali e i prodotti scalari, e continueremo
a fare uso di questi concetti e ne introdurremo anche di nuovi
man mano che ne avremo bisogno.
In questa lezione ci concentreremo
su tre esempi fondamentali e importanti: il teletrasporto quantistico, la codifica superdensa e il gioco CHSH,
chiamato anche disuguaglianza CHSH e non sempre descritto come un gioco.
Non si tratta solo di esempi
casuali per illustrare come funziona l'informazione quantistica, sono davvero parti fondamentali
dell'informazione quantistica e
emergono in contesti diversi e a volte inaspettati all'interno dell'informazione
e del calcolo quantistico.
L'entanglement svolge un ruolo fondamentale in tutti e tre questi
esempi, ed è proprio l'entanglement a farli funzionare
e a renderli interessanti. Quindi, questa lezione sarà, in un certo senso, la nostra prima occasione per
vedere l'entanglement in azione
e per iniziare a esplorare cosa rende l'entanglement così interessante.
La panoramica della
lezione è molto semplice: analizzeremo uno per uno
i tre esempi che ho appena menzionato,
il teletrasporto quantistico,
la codifica superdensa e il gioco CHSH.
Discuteremo di cosa sono queste cose e di cosa le rende interessanti e faremo delle analisi che spiegano esattamente come funzionano
a livello matematico.
Prima di arrivare al primo
dei tre esempi, che è il teletrasporto quantistico, è opportuno presentare prima
i personaggi,
Alice e Bob, nel caso in cui
non li conosca.
Alice e Bob sono nomi
dati a entità o agenti ipotetici in sistemi, protocolli, giochi,
e in qualsiasi altro tipo di interazione che preveda lo scambio di informazioni.
Sono comparsi per la prima volta nel
contesto della crittografia negli anni Settanta, ma la
convenzione di usare questi nomi in questo modo è diventata molto comune
in un contesto molto più ampio da allora. L'idea è che questi
sono nomi molto comuni, almeno in alcune parti del mondo, e iniziano con le lettere A e B,
ed è anche comodo
riferirsi ad Alice e Bob usando i pronomi lei e lui solo per brevità.
Immaginiamo in genere che Alice e Bob si trovino in luoghi diversi e che abbiano
obiettivi e comportamenti diversi
a seconda di ciò di cui stiamo parlando.
Per esempio, se stiamo
parlando di comunicazione, ovvero della trasmissione di informazioni, potremmo decidere
che Alice è il mittente
e Bob è il destinatario
di qualsiasi informazione venga trasmessa.
A volte Alice e Bob
cooperano, il che è molto comune, ma a volte
competono o possono avere obiettivi diversi che potrebbero
essere o meno coerenti
tra loro, ma tutto ciò
deve essere chiarito nella situazione specifica.
Naturalmente, rappresentano astrazioni e non necessariamente esseri umani reali.
Possiamo anche introdurre
personaggi aggiuntivi come Charlie e
Diane o nomi diversi che rappresentano
diversi ruoli, come Eve
per una spia o Mallory per qualcuno che si comporta in modo malevolo
a seconda del contesto.
In ogni caso, vedremo Alice e Bob in tutti e tre gli
esempi di cui parleremo in questa lezione e di tanto in tanto
nel resto della serie. Farò anche alcune
osservazioni sull'entanglement prima di passare ai tre esempi.
Nella lezione due, abbiamo incontrato questo esempio di stato entangled di due qubit.
È uno dei quattro stati di Bell, e si potrebbe dire che
questo particolare stato rappresenta l'esempio archetipico
di uno stato quantistico entangled.
Abbiamo incontrato anche
questo esempio di stato probabilistico di due bit.
È in qualche modo analogo allo
stato entangled, ma non è entangled,
l'entanglement è un fenomeno
esclusivamente quantistico,
essenzialmente per definizione.
Esiste una precisa definizione matematica di cosa sia l'entanglement e sostanzialmente ciò che quella definizione
dice è che l'entanglement
è una correlazione quantistica non classica.
Ma questo non è
molto utile a livello intuitivo, è una definizione dell'entanglement in termini di ciò che l'entanglement non è,
ed è probabilmente per questo
motivo che è davvero piuttosto difficile spiegare cosa sia l'entanglement e cosa lo renda speciale
in termini intuitivi.
Quando le persone cercano di
spiegare cos'è l'entanglement in termini intuitivi, si
sentono spesso spiegazioni che non distinguono davvero questi due stati
in modo significativo. Potresti sentire l'idea
che se misuri uno dei due qubit entangled,
allora lo stato dell'altro
WEBVTT
viene in qualche modo influenzato istantaneamente, o che lo stato dei due qubit non può essere descritto separatamente
o che i due qubit
mantengono in qualche modo una memoria l'uno dell'altro o addirittura che
sono emotivamente legati in qualche modo.
Ma perché queste proprietà
non sono vere per questo stato?
Questi due bit sono intimamente connessi, ognuno ha una memoria
perfetta dell'altro in senso letterale, ma
non è uno stato entangled.
Un modo per spiegare cosa rende
speciale l'entanglement e cosa rende questo stato
molto diverso da quell'altro è spiegare cosa
possiamo fare con l'entanglement
o cosa possiamo vedere accadere
grazie all'entanglement che va oltre le scelte che facciamo su come rappresentiamo la nostra
conoscenza usando i vettori.
Tutti e tre gli esempi
di cui parleremo in questa lezione hanno questa natura, nel senso che illustrano
cose che possiamo fare con l'entanglement che non
possiamo fare con questo stato
o con qualsiasi stato correlato classicamente.
Infatti, è molto comune nello studio dell'informazione e del calcolo quantistico considerare l'entanglement come una risorsa
attraverso la quale diversi
compiti possono essere svolti.
E quando lo facciamo, consideriamo questo stato come rappresentante
un'unità di entanglement.
Chiamiamo questa unità di
entanglement e-bit, dove la e sta per
entangled o entanglement.
È vero che si tratta di due qubit, ma come quantità di
entanglement, è un e-bit.
Puoi anche considerare una coppia
di bit classici ordinari nello stato probabilistico
correlato di prima come una risorsa che vale
un bit di casualità condivisa.
Può essere molto utile in
crittografia condividere un bit casuale con qualcuno, supponendo
che nessun altro sappia qual è quel bit, in modo che
possa essere usato come chiave privata
o come parte di una chiave privata, ad esempio, a scopo di cifratura.
Ma in questa lezione, la nostra attenzione sarà su questo stato entangled e
sulle cose che possiamo fare con esso.
E solo per chiarire la terminologia, quando diciamo che Alice
e Bob condividono un e-bit, intendiamo dire che
Alice ha un qubit chiamato A,
Bob ha un qubit chiamato B, e insieme la coppia A, B
si trova nello stato Phi plus.
Non è importante quali nomi
scegliamo per i due qubit, ovviamente, potremmo
scegliere nomi diversi, ma per tutta questa lezione
useremo questi nomi
per chiarezza. Il primo esempio della lezione
è il teletrasporto quantistico,
che d'ora in poi chiameremo semplicemente
teletrasporto per brevità.
Il teletrasporto è un protocollo che consente a un mittente di
trasmettere informazioni quantistiche a un destinatario usando solo l'entanglement
e la comunicazione classica per
realizzare quella trasmissione.
Non ha assolutamente nulla a che fare con la tipica interpretazione
della parola teletrasporto nella fantascienza, ovvero che la materia scompare
in un luogo e appare in un altro.
Il teletrasporto quantistico è solo un nome che vuole evocare quell'immagine o quella metafora, per così dire.
Ciò che viene teletrasportato è
l'informazione quantistica e non la materia, e questo avviene
attraverso una trasmissione di informazioni classiche
insieme all'entanglement.
Per capire esattamente
come funziona il teletrasporto, è utile iniziare
preparando il terreno, per così dire.
Quello che faremo è immaginare uno scenario che coinvolge Alice e Bob e
quello scenario è il seguente:
Alice ha un qubit chiamato Q che
vorrebbe trasmettere a Bob, nel senso che vuole che Bob tenga nelle sue mani
un qubit che si trova esattamente
nello stesso stato in cui si trova Q quando iniziano il protocollo.
In altre parole, stiamo parlando del problema fondamentale della
trasmissione di informazioni o comunicazione.
Abbiamo un mittente chiamato Alice
e un destinatario chiamato Bob e Alice vuole inviare
informazioni quantistiche sotto forma di un qubit a Bob.
C'è però un vincolo, ovvero che Alice non è
in grado di inviare fisicamente Q a Bob; tutto ciò che può fare è inviare informazioni classiche a Bob.
Alice e Bob hanno anche
una risorsa aggiuntiva, ovvero che condividono un e-bit.
Questo è dunque lo scenario; è
facile immaginare situazioni in cui il vincolo che
Alice non possa inviare fisicamente Q
a Bob sia un'astrazione ragionevole.
Se Alice e Bob si trovassero su
continenti diversi, ad esempio, o se Alice non sapesse
la posizione esatta di Bob, inviare fisicamente un qubit
sarebbe probabilmente piuttosto difficile.
Ma la comunicazione classica
non solo è possibile ma anche piuttosto economica
in quelle circostanze.
Ora, ci si potrebbe chiedere se è possibile per Alice e Bob svolgere questo compito senza nemmeno aver bisogno dell'e-bit condiviso.
In altre parole, esiste
un modo per trasmettere un qubit usando solo la
comunicazione classica?
La risposta è no, non è possibile trasmettere informazioni quantistiche usando solo la comunicazione classica, e non è troppo difficile dimostrarlo
usando alcune nozioni di base di
teoria dell'informazione quantistica, che vedremo nella
terza unità della serie.
Per ora, un modo intuitivo
di pensarci è pensare al teorema di no-cloning.
WEBVTT
Immagina che ci fosse un modo
per inviare informazioni quantistiche usando solo la comunicazione classica,
ma la comunicazione classica
può essere facilmente copiata e trasmessa in broadcast, quindi ciò significa
che la comunicazione classica
potrebbe essere trasmessa a due
destinatari, Bob e Charlie, diciamo.
Se ricevessero entrambi le
stesse informazioni classiche da Alice, avrebbero
entrambi finito per avere Q?
Ciò suggerirebbe che abbiamo clonato Q, ma sappiamo che è impossibile.
Solo come nota a margine, osserviamo
che è certamente possibile descrivere
i vettori di stato quantistico usando informazioni classiche.
Ogni vettore di stato quantistico
che vedrai nella serie ti viene descritto
usando informazioni classiche che sono state trasmesse a qualsiasi
dispositivo su cui stai guardando.
In generale, potremmo immaginare
di descrivere qualsiasi stato in cui si trova Q usando bit classici,
magari con una certa precisione,
ma questa non è comunicazione quantistica, è solo descrivere
gli stati quantistici come vettori, e torneremo sulla
distinzione tra loro
tra poco.
Tornando allo scenario, però, e lavorando con
l'ipotesi che Alice e Bob condividano effettivamente un e-bit, vedremo che Alice e Bob
hanno tutto il necessario
per portare a termine il compito, e questo è ciò che fa il protocollo di
teletrasporto quantistico, utilizzando specificamente due bit
di comunicazione classica.
Prima di entrare in
questi dettagli, però, permettimi di fare alcune veloci
osservazioni solo per assicurarmi che le ipotesi siano chiare.
Prima di tutto, stiamo ipotizzando
qui che lo stato di Q sia sconosciuto ad Alice e
Bob, quindi in particolare,
Alice non può inviare a Bob una
descrizione dello stato Q perché in generale non lo conosce.
Dobbiamo anche considerare la possibilità che Q sia correlato con altri sistemi, inclusa la possibilità
che sia entangled
con altri sistemi e la
trasmissione di questo qubit a Bob deve preservare quelle correlazioni.
Infine, ho menzionato
il teorema di no-cloning quando stavo parlando di
cercare di comunicare qubit classicamente, ma
c'è un altro collegamento qui
con il teorema di no-cloning, ovvero che se Bob
riceve la trasmissione di questo qubit Q da Alice,
allora lei non deve più averlo
perché Q non può essere clonato, e questo è solo qualcosa da tenere a mente
mentre consideriamo il protocollo di teletrasporto.
Il protocollo di teletrasporto
può essere descritto in modo abbastanza semplice e diretto con il diagramma a quantum circuit come puoi vedere qui.
È leggermente stilizzato nel
senso che rappresenta la separazione tra la parte di Alice e quella di Bob, ma per il resto è solo
un diagramma a quantum circuit,
tutto ciò che è sopra la linea tratteggiata
rappresenta le azioni di Alice e tutto ciò che è sotto
rappresenta le azioni di Bob.
Il tempo scorre da sinistra a destra come sempre, e vediamo che iniziamo
con questi due qubit qui in uno stato Phi plus,
quindi questo è l'e-bit
con cui iniziano Alice e Bob.
Possiamo mettere etichette sui qubit per chiarire quale è
quale, quindi questo è il qubit A, e questo è il qubit
B che formano l'e-bit,
e questo è il qubit Q che
Alice desidera trasmettere a Bob.
Qui ipotizziamo che
lo stato di questo qubit Q sia Psi, ma un po' più avanti considereremo la possibilità
che Q sia entangled
con qualche altro sistema. E ciò che il diagramma afferma perché abbiamo scritto psi qui in basso,
è che questo circuit
trasmette effettivamente qualsiasi stato psi che avevamo
qui nella parte di Alice a qui nella parte di Bob,
l'unica comunicazione
che attraversa la
linea tra Alice e Bob sono i due bit classici
rappresentati da queste doppie linee qui.
Restringiamo un po' questo
diagramma così da avere un po' più di spazio ed esaminiamo il
circuit più da vicino.
Ho già descritto
le condizioni iniziali, ma solo per riepilogare, Alice tiene un qubit A
e Bob tiene un qubit B,
dove A e B insieme
si trovano in uno stato Phi plus, quindi questo è il significato di condividere un e-bit.
Alice ha anche questo qubit Q che desidera trasmettere a Bob, e stiamo considerando il caso in cui Q si trova in un qualsiasi stato quantistico Psi.
Ora, non sappiamo nulla
di come Alice e Bob siano entrati in possesso di questo e-bit.
Potrebbe essere che ce l'abbiano
da molto tempo, forse lo hanno creato qualche tempo fa quando si trovavano nello stesso posto
e lo hanno conservato
per questa occasione, ma quei dettagli non sono rilevanti qui.
I passi successivi, che rappresentano
il protocollo di teletrasporto vero e proprio, sono i seguenti, e solo per essere chiari,
questi sono i passi che
il diagramma descrive e li scriviamo
in parole in modo che sia chiaro cosa
il diagramma esprime.
Alice esegue prima un'operazione
controlled-NOT dove il qubit Q che
vuole inviare a Bob è il control e il
qubit A è il target.
Il passo successivo è che
esegue un'operazione Hadamard su Q, e poi misura
i due qubit che tiene,
A e Q rispetto a
misurazioni della base standard, e lasciamo che a minuscolo sia il risultato della misurazione del qubit A,
WEBVTT
e lasciamo che b minuscolo sia il risultato della misurazione del qubit Q.
Alice poi invia quei
due bit classici a Bob e questa è l'unica comunicazione coinvolta in questo protocollo, ed è indicata nel diagramma
dal fatto che questi due
bit attraversano la linea tratteggiata tra Alice e Bob,
che puoi pensare come rappresentante qualsiasi
distanza che li separa.
Dopo che Bob riceve i bit
a e b, fa due cose.
Prima, se a è uguale a uno, allora esegue un'operazione X
o in altre parole, un NOT gate sul suo qubit B,
e altrimenti se a è uguale a zero, allora non lo fa.
E in modo analogo,
se b è uguale a uno, allora Bob esegue un'operazione Z
o un Z-gate o un phase flip
anche sul qubit b e come
prima, se b è uguale a zero, allora non lo fa.
Tutto ciò è indicato nella figura dove abbiamo questi controlled-X
e controlled-Z gate dove i control sono
i due bit classici.
Non devi pensare a questi gate come a gate di control
se non vuoi, questo è solo un modo comodo
per esprimere ciò che vogliamo
nella forma di un diagramma a circuit. Il punto è che Bob applica
un X-gate al qubit b se a è uguale a uno e
poi applica un Z-gate
al qubit b se B è uguale a uno.
E per comodità in seguito possiamo scrivere esplicitamente
l'operazione combinata che Bob esegue sul suo qubit b,
a seconda dei bit classici
che Alice invia.
Questo è dunque il protocollo di teletrasporto, è abbastanza semplice in realtà, il
fatto che funzioni davvero è un'altra questione
e sebbene l'analisi
non sia così complicata,
non dovresti sentirti come se ti stessi perdendo qualcosa se non capisci immediatamente perché funziona.
Ecco perché dobbiamo fare
un'analisi e questo è ciò che faremo dopo.
Per analizzare il protocollo di teletrasporto, lo esamineremo passo per passo per vedere quali sono gli stati
dei tre qubit in diversi momenti.
Considereremo prima
il caso in cui il qubit in cima si trova nello stato alphaZero più beta uno, dove alpha e beta
sono qualsiasi numero complesso
che rendano questo vettore
un vettore unitario.
Questo è il qubit Q che
Alice sta cercando di trasmettere, ma in questo momento non ci interessa davvero come si chiama.
Un po' più avanti daremo
un'occhiata alla situazione in cui questo qubit è
entangled con un altro sistema, ma questo è un buon punto di partenza per mantenere le cose semplici
e per vedere come funziona l'analisi
in modo un po' più chiaro.
Se consideriamo lo stato dei
tre qubit insieme qui all'inizio, vediamo
che questo stato ha la forma che vedi qui.
I primi due qubit si trovano
nello stato Phi plus, il terzo qubit è quello in cima
secondo la convenzione
per l'ordinamento dei qubit che
ho descritto nella lezione precedente, quindi prendiamo il prodotto tensoriale per ottenere lo stato dei
tre qubit insieme.
Possiamo espandere questa espressione
sostituendo prima la definizione dello stato Phi plus e poi calcolando il prodotto tensoriale
e otteniamo lo stato
che vedi qui.
Non è sempre la migliore
strategia, tra l'altro, espandere completamente
un vettore come questo, in generale è una buona idea aspettare finché
non si ha una buona ragione per farlo.
Ma qui abbiamo una ragione, ovvero che vorremmo
calcolare l'azione di questo controlled NOT gate e scrivendo lo stato in questa forma,
possiamo farlo molto facilmente.
E in particolare, questo è
lo stato dei tre qubit dopo che il controlled NOT gate è applicato.
Il terzo qubit è il qubit di control perché è quello che si trova
in cima secondo la nostra convenzione, e il secondo qubit,
che è quello in mezzo,
è il target, quindi operiamo semplicemente
sulle ket di conseguenza, se il terzo bit è
zero, non succede nulla,
e se il terzo bit è uno,
allora invertiamo il secondo bit.
Poi eseguiamo il Hadamard
gate sul terzo qubit, possiamo scrivere il vettore risultante come puoi vedere
qui sostituendo lo
stato plus e lo stato minus allo stato zero e allo stato uno.
E se vogliamo avere abbastanza
spazio per espandere questo, dovremo
ridurlo un po' e ora, sostituendo gli stati
plus e minus
con le loro definizioni,
portando la radice quadrata di due al denominatore, otteniamo lo stato che vedi qui.
E espandendo quello, otteniamo lo stato che vedi qui.
Questo è dunque lo stato dei tre qubit dopo che Alice esegue le sue due operazioni.
Alice poi misura
e se vogliamo analizzare le misurazioni, quello che facciamo è isolare i vettori della base standard
per i sistemi che vengono misurati
proprio come ne abbiamo parlato nella lezione due, e se lo facciamo in questo caso specifico, questo è ciò che otteniamo.
E se guardi quell'espressione
per un momento, potrebbe sembrare un po' strana perché ora sembra che il primo qubit,
che è il qubit in basso,
dipenda in qualche modo da alpha e beta, anche se
a questo punto non c'è stata alcuna comunicazione attraverso la linea tratteggiata,
WEBVTT
ma è solo un'illusione. Ricorda che gli scalari scorrono
liberamente attraverso i prodotti tensoriali, quindi non c'è davvero alcun senso
in cui alpha e beta
siano associati al primo qubit.
Tutto ciò che abbiamo davvero fatto
qui è usare le parentesi in accordo con la
multilinearità dei prodotti tensoriali.
In ogni caso, questa è la forma di cui abbiamo bisogno per vedere cosa fa la misurazione, e possiamo vedere subito una
cosa interessante
ovvero che le probabilità dei quattro possibili risultati di misurazione sono sempre uniformi.
La probabilità di misurare ogni
coppia di risultati di misurazione è un quarto, quindi, in particolare,
non c'è alcuna dipendenza
da alpha e beta.
Possiamo vederlo in ogni caso calcolando il quadrato della norma euclidea di
qualsiasi vettore che viene tensorizzato con il vettore della base standard che abbiamo isolato,
e in ogni caso abbiamo un quarto che otteniamo elevando al quadrato un mezzo moltiplicato per il valore assoluto al quadrato di alpha
più il valore assoluto
al quadrato di beta, che è uno, e quindi otteniamo un quarto in ogni caso.
È piuttosto importante in
effetti che le probabilità di questi diversi risultati non dipendano in alcun modo dal qubit che
Alice vuole trasmettere.
Non potrebbe accadere che uno stato arbitrario entri qui sopra ed esca qui sotto mentre una misurazione rivela
informazioni su quello stato.
Se vuoi ottenere informazioni su uno stato quantistico arbitrario, dovrai disturbare
quello stato in generale.
Ecco una tabella che descrive non solo le probabilità
dei diversi risultati, ma anche lo stato dei
tre qubit insieme
condizionato a ciascun possibile
risultato di misurazione.
Otteniamo questo normalizzando i vettori tensorizzati con i diversi
stati della base standard, ma è facile in questo caso,
eliminiamo semplicemente il fattore di un mezzo per ottenere un vettore unitario.
Quindi, ciò che abbiamo immediatamente
dopo che Alice misura è che Alice ha due bit
casuali uniformi e basta.
In particolare, non ha più
lo stato originale e non ha alcuna
informazione su di esso, ha solo bit casuali.
Lo stato di Bob ora
dipende da alpha e beta oltre che dai risultati della misurazione.
Se immaginiamo momentaneamente
che Alice non abbia ancora inviato i risultati della misurazione
in modo che Bob non sappia quali sono i risultati della misurazione,
allora non sarebbe in grado
di ottenere alcuna informazione su alpha e beta
misurando il suo qubit.
Queste quattro possibilità
che abbiamo qui sono sufficientemente mescolate da garantire che nessuna informazione
su alpha e beta
possa mai essere ottenuta
attraverso una misurazione. Questo deve essere vero a livello intuitivo perché altrimenti avremmo
comunicazione più veloce della luce.
Alice certamente non può
trasmettere informazioni a Bob senza inviare nulla, ma ovviamente Alice
invia i risultati della misurazione
a Bob, quindi espandiamo la tabella per vedere cosa succede quando
Bob esegue le sue operazioni.
In questa colonna qui, abbiamo le diverse operazioni che Bob esegue effettivamente per ciascuno dei possibili
risultati delle misurazioni
come abbiamo osservato prima,
e se procediamo uno per uno e applichiamo quell'
operazione al qubit di Bob, che è il primo, B,
vediamo che otteniamo lo stesso
risultato in tutti e quattro i casi e quel risultato è lo stato originale.
Quindi, lo stato originale del qubit Q è stato teletrasportato con successo in B.
Se Bob vuole rinominare il suo qubit e chiamarlo Q a questo punto, è certamente libero di farlo, ma il punto è che ora
tiene lo stato originale
che aveva Alice e ovviamente, per necessità, Alice non lo ha più.
Nota anche che l'e-bit
è stato effettivamente consumato attraverso questo processo,
il teletrasporto ha un costo
e il costo è un e-bit e due bit classici di comunicazione, e quando il protocollo è
finito, l'e-bit è sparito.
Abbiamo ora stabilito che
il protocollo di teletrasporto funziona correttamente con l'ipotesi che il qubit in cima si trovi in uno stato quantistico
della forma alpha moltiplicato ket
zero più beta moltiplicato ket uno.
Ma cosa succede se il
qubit in cima è entangled con qualche altro sistema, come
uno dei nostri qubit aggiuntivi
come abbiamo qui sullo schermo? Potremmo voler usare il teletrasporto
in tali circostanze.
Forse Alice e Bob hanno effettivamente
intenzione di eseguire il teletrasporto 100 volte in modo che Alice possa trasmettere
un registro quantistico di 100 qubit
a Bob, un qubit alla volta.
O forse questi qubit aggiuntivi
non sono nemmeno in possesso di Alice
e li ha qualcun altro, forse Alice non sa nemmeno
che esistono.
La domanda è: il teletrasporto
funziona ancora anche quando il qubit che viene teletrasportato è entangled con un altro sistema?
Qui, lo stato del qubit Q insieme al sistema aggiuntivo
che stiamo considerando è espresso come puoi vedere qui in alto
dove gamma zero e
gamma uno sono vettori unitari che rappresentano stati quantistici
di questo sistema aggiuntivo.
Possiamo sempre scrivere uno stato arbitrario del sistema combinato in questo modo.
In realtà non abbiamo nemmeno
bisogno di alpha e beta qui, ma se li includiamo,
possiamo prendere gamma zero e gamma uno come vettori unitari
e ciò renderà il
collegamento con il caso più semplice che abbiamo già considerato più trasparente.
WEBVTT
Possiamo fare un'analisi
simile a quella che abbiamo già fatto, ma dove teniamo traccia
anche di questo sistema aggiuntivo.
È un po' più complicata perché abbiamo il sistema aggiuntivo, ma
l'idea è esattamente la stessa; ecco un riassunto molto rapido.
Questo è lo stato iniziale, ecco lo stato dopo
il controlled NOT gate,
ed ecco lo stato dopo
l'operazione Hadamard.
Se espandiamo queste cose,
possiamo esprimere quello stato come puoi vedere qui,
questo è lo stato immediatamente
prima delle misurazioni di Alice, e se esaminiamo le
possibilità come prima
e consideriamo cosa
succede quando Bob applica qualsiasi operazione che deve applicare,
allora troviamo che in effetti
lo stato corretto viene fuori e il protocollo funziona come previsto.
In questa tabella, tra l'altro, usiamo la lettera R per
riferirci a questo sistema aggiuntivo, e puoi vedere che stiamo
usando un trucco abbastanza semplice,
ovvero decidere che preferiremmo, almeno momentaneamente, ordinare
i sistemi come B, R, A, Q
perché è più conveniente per scrivere gli stati qui.
Secondo il diagramma, i sistemi dovrebbero essere
ordinati come B, A, Q, R,
ma finché lo rendiamo chiaro, possiamo scegliere un ordine diverso
che sia più conveniente.
In sostanza, tutto ciò che accade in questa analisi è lo stesso
di ciò che è accaduto nell'analisi più semplice,
ma capita che abbiamo
questi vettori aggiuntivi, gamma zero e gamma uno
che essenzialmente vengono trascinati con noi.
Abbiamo sempre gamma zero
quando c'è un fattore di alpha e gamma uno quando
c'è un fattore di beta e alla fine
tutto funziona correttamente.
Questo in realtà non è affatto sorprendente, abbiamo un processo fisico che agisce come l'operazione identità su un qubit
in uno stato quantistico arbitrario, e c'è un solo
modo in cui ciò può accadere ed è che l'operazione
è l'operazione identità.
È un po' più facile da spiegare usando la formulazione generale
dell'informazione quantistica, ma il punto è che per linearità,
non avevamo davvero bisogno di fare questa analisi aggiuntiva.
Una volta che sappiamo che
il teletrasporto funziona correttamente per un singolo qubit in isolamento, possiamo concludere che c'è
solo una cosa possibile
che può descrivere ciò che fa il protocollo, e cioè che implementa
l'operazione identità dove un qubit entra qui
ed esce qui, agendo effettivamente come un canale quantistico
perfetto senza rumore.
Solo alcune veloci osservazioni
sul teletrasporto prima di passare al
secondo esempio della lezione, che è la codifica superdensa.
Prima di tutto, penso che sia importante chiarire che il teletrasporto non è un'applicazione dell'informazione quantistica, è un protocollo
e in particolare è un
protocollo per eseguire la comunicazione quantistica.
Affinché il teletrasporto,
come l'ho descritto, sia utile, deve esserci una ragione per eseguire la comunicazione quantistica.
In secondo luogo, è ragionevole speculare che il teletrasporto possa un
giorno diventare un modo standard
per comunicare informazioni quantistiche, e in particolare un processo noto come distillazione dell'entanglement
potrebbe essere potenzialmente usato
come modo per comunicare qubit in modo affidabile. Se Alice e Bob sanno che
comunicheranno informazioni quantistiche o hanno la necessità di comunicare
informazioni quantistiche, allora questo processo di distillazione dell'entanglement
potrebbe essere usato per convertire un numero maggiore di e-bit rumorosi
in un numero minore
di e-bit di alta qualità che potrebbero poi essere usati per un teletrasporto senza rumore o quasi senza rumore.
L'idea è che il processo
di distillazione dell'entanglement non è così delicato in un certo senso, potremmo accettare perdite e
se non funziona,
potremmo semplicemente riprovare, mentre i qubit effettivi che
vorremmo comunicare potrebbero essere considerati molto più preziosi.
Ovviamente, tutto ciò è speculazione, ma il punto è che non è difficile ipotizzare situazioni
in cui il teletrasporto
potrebbe essere un modo molto pratico
per comunicare qubit.
E l'ultima osservazione
riguardante il teletrasporto è che l'idea alla base del teletrasporto e il modo in cui funziona
è abbastanza fondamentale
nell'informazione e nel calcolo quantistico, il teletrasporto è davvero una pietra miliare della teoria
dell'informazione quantistica e le variazioni
sull'idea compaiono spesso anche,
è solo un esempio, ci sono proposte per
implementare diversi quantum gate
usando il teletrasporto, ma
dove vengono scelti stati iniziali e misurazioni diversi in modo che il risultato
sia applicare un'operazione scelta
piuttosto che comunicare.
Il prossimo esempio è la codifica superdensa.
Come il teletrasporto quantistico,
la codifica superdensa è un protocollo e ciò che realizza è complementare al teletrasporto.
Mentre il teletrasporto consente
la trasmissione di un qubit usando un e-bit e due
bit classici di comunicazione,
la codifica superdensa consente
la trasmissione di due bit classici usando
un e-bit e un qubit di comunicazione quantistica.
Quindi, in breve, la codifica superdensa consente la trasmissione
di informazioni classiche e il motivo per cui si chiama codifica superdensa
WEBVTT
è che consente a due
bit classici di comunicazione di essere compressi in un singolo qubit,
ma dobbiamo consumare un
e-bit per realizzarlo.
Ecco una spiegazione più precisa
della configurazione.
Ancora una volta, abbiamo Alice e Bob, dove Alice è il mittente
e Bob è il destinatario, e questa volta Alice ha due bit classici
che vuole inviare a Bob.
Alice può inviare a Bob un singolo qubit e Alice e Bob condividono
un e-bit che possono usare per aiutarsi a svolgere il loro compito,
ovvero che Bob riceva
i due bit classici.
Ora, in un certo senso questo compito potrebbe sembrare meno interessante del compito che
realizza il teletrasporto,
specialmente se consideriamo
che inviare qubit è significativamente più
difficile o impegnativo che inviare bit classici,
il che è un punto di vista abbastanza ragionevole, ma è sicuramente interessante che sia possibile farlo.
Una ragione per cui è interessante
è che è in effetti impossibile realizzare
questo compito di trasmettere due bit classici di informazione
usando un singolo qubit senza
usare l'e-bit.
Lo sappiamo grazie a un famoso teorema noto come teorema di Holevo.
Il teorema di Holevo è
più generale di questo, e l'enunciato preciso
del teorema di Holevo è un po' tecnico e richiede qualche spiegazione,
ma una sua implicazione
è che non puoi trasmettere alcun numero di bit classici di comunicazione usando meno qubit di
comunicazione quantistica da sola.
Se vuoi trasmettere in modo affidabile due bit classici di
informazione usando qubit e non hai
un e-bit da usare,
dovrai inviare due qubit, quindi tanto vale che memorizzino i bit che vuoi trasmettere.
Un altro motivo per cui la codifica superdensa
è interessante è per la stretta
relazione complementare che ha con il teletrasporto, e
torneremo su questo
un po' più tardi. Ecco una descrizione a quantum circuit del protocollo di codifica superdensa.
Per questo, non
elencherò tutti i passaggi, ma invece ci atterremo alla descrizione tramite diagramma a circuit.
Come puoi vedere, abbiamo ancora
Alice e Bob, dove Alice è in cima
e Bob è in fondo.
Ecco l'e-bit che viene
inizialmente condiviso tra Alice e Bob, che è stato
in qualche modo stabilito prima che il protocollo venga eseguito.
Alice ha due bit classici, A e B, che puoi vedere qui in alto
e attraverso il protocollo che il circuit descrive,
questi due bit classici
finiranno nelle mani di Bob.
C'è solo un qubit
che attraversa la linea tra Alice e Bob, e ovviamente non vengono
inviati bit classici,
è la trasmissione
dei due bit classici che è il punto del protocollo.
Noterai anche che ha
esattamente gli stessi componenti usati nel teletrasporto, abbiamo un controlled NOT
gate, un Hadamard gate,
e un Z e un X-gate
controllati da bit classici.
Sono disposti diversamente, però, quindi passiamo all'analisi per vedere come funziona.
Per analizzare come funziona la codifica superdensa, iniziamo scrivendo
la base di Bell, che è davvero al
cuore dell'analisi.
Quello che faremo è
prima esaminare l'effetto che le azioni di Alice
hanno sullo stato Phi plus, e ciò che vedremo è
che Alice trasforma questo
stato Phi plus in uno
dei quattro stati di Bell a seconda dei bit
che vuole inviare.
Quindi, scriviamo una tabella in modo da tenere
traccia di ciò che sta succedendo.
Prima, se A e B sono entrambi zero, allora né il Z-gate né
il X-gate viene applicato, quindi le azioni di Alice non fanno nulla,
il che significa che Phi
plus viene mappato in Phi plus.
Possiamo anche esprimerlo come un'equazione come vedi qui,
niente succede al qubit di Alice e niente succede al qubit di Bob
e non fare nulla è rappresentato
dalla matrice identità.
Ora, cosa succede se A è uguale a zero e B è uguale a uno?
Poiché B è uguale a uno, applichiamo il Z-gate e
non applichiamo il X-gate perché A è uguale a zero
e vediamo che l'effetto complessivo è che Alice esegue un Z-gate.
Alice è a destra
perché è in cima, sebbene in questo caso specifico non farebbe
alcuna differenza, l'effetto è che
lo stato Phi plus viene
trasformato in Phi minus, il che puoi intuire
da queste espressioni se ricordi come funziona un Z-gate.
Quindi, possiamo aggiungere questo alla nostra tabella; ci sono altri due casi da esaminare, se A è uguale a uno
e B è uguale a zero,
allora Alice esegue un
X-gate che trasforma Phi plus in Chi plus, e se A è uguale a uno
e B è uguale a uno,
allora Alice esegue Z, poi
X e otteniamo Chi minus.
Quindi, la nostra tabella ci dice cosa succede nei quattro casi possibili, ovvero che Alice sceglie effettivamente quale
WEBVTT
dei quattro stati di Bell vuole
condividere con Bob, e ha la libertà di scegliere agendo sul suo qubit da sola
e questo è un aspetto abbastanza interessante dell'entanglement.
Alice poi invia il suo qubit
a Bob; a questo punto, Bob tiene uno dei quattro stati di Bell e deve solo
capire quale è
per recuperare i bit.
E possiamo verificare che
un controlled NOT gate seguito da un Hadamard gate
come abbiamo nel diagramma faccia la cosa giusta.
Non li esaminerò in dettaglio, ma se scegli di farlo, troverai che l'effetto è
come vedi qui nella tabella.
Un modo per verificarlo
è semplicemente calcolare. In alternativa, possiamo riconoscere che in realtà abbiamo già
fatto questo al contrario
nella lezione precedente. Nella lezione precedente avevamo
prima il Hadamard gate e poi il controlled NOT gate
e abbiamo visto che quel circuit
mappava gli stati della base standard agli stati di Bell con un fastidioso
segno meno in uno dei casi.
Quando invertiamo l'ordine dei gate e consideriamo il fatto
che entrambi questi gate sono i propri inversi,
otteniamo l'inverso,
e quindi in questo
caso l'azione va nella direzione opposta
e il segno meno può scegliere da quale
lato stare,
ma per il resto è dove deve essere, e a questo punto è
immediato che la misurazione rivela i valori corretti,
il segno meno qui non ci disturba perché uno compare con
probabilità uno in questo caso, e questo è tutto ciò che c'è nell'analisi.
In sostanza, Alice sceglie uno stato di Bell e Bob capisce quale è.
Solo un paio di brevi osservazioni
sulla codifica superdensa prima di andare avanti; innanzitutto, dobbiamo riconoscere
che la codifica superdensa
probabilmente non è destinata
ad essere utile o pratica in alcun senso come mezzo per
trasmettere informazioni classiche.
La comunicazione classica
è molto economica e inviare fisicamente qubit è impegnativo per usare un eufemismo,
e finché questo è il caso, non ci aspetteremmo alcun
vantaggio pratico dalla codifica superdensa.
Ma solo perché probabilmente non sarà pratica non significa che la codifica superdensa
non sia interessante.
È in effetti molto interessante, in primo luogo, l'idea sottostante è
davvero abbastanza fondamentale,
e quando mi riferisco all'idea sottostante, intendo l'idea che se Alice
condivide uno stato di Bell con Bob,
allora può scegliere di cambiare quello stato in qualsiasi altro stato di Bell
da sola, non ha bisogno dell'aiuto di Bob
per farlo.
Questo è un esempio specifico
che riguarda gli stati di Bell, ma c'è un'idea sottostante più generale che riguarda la libertà che un giocatore
ha di trasformare uno stato entangled condiviso con un altro giocatore, e capire esattamente
quale sia quella libertà
è un passo importante per capire l'informazione quantistica e vedremo esattamente come descrivere quella libertà in termini semplici
ed eleganti nella
terza unità della serie.
La codifica superdensa fornisce anche
un esempio concreto di cosa puoi fare con l'entanglement, ovvero consentire la trasmissione di due bit classici
inviando un singolo qubit. Come ho già menzionato, questo
è provabilmente impossibile per il teorema di Holevo senza entanglement.
Possiamo anche considerare il teletrasporto e la codifica superdensa insieme, e vediamo che stabiliscono un'equivalenza
tra un qubit di comunicazione quantistica e due bit di comunicazione classica.
Finché sei disposto
a spendere un e-bit, puoi effettivamente
convertire uno nell'altro.
Il teletrasporto consente la
comunicazione di un qubit usando due bit classici di comunicazione e la codifica superdensa va nell'altra direzione
e consente due bit classici
di comunicazione usando un qubit di comunicazione quantistica.
Senza spendere l'e-bit, però, non puoi trasformare
nessuno dei due nell'altro, è l'entanglement che
rende ciò possibile.
Il terzo e ultimo esempio
che tratteremo in questa lezione non è un protocollo ma un
gioco noto come il gioco CHSH.
Quando parliamo di un gioco in questo contesto, non stiamo parlando di qualcosa che si vuole
giocare per divertimento o sport,
ma piuttosto di un'astrazione matematica nel senso della teoria dei giochi, per esempio.
Le astrazioni matematiche dei giochi sono comunemente studiate in
economia e informatica, per esempio, e c'è
parecchio valore
nell'astrazione, quindi i giochi non sono sempre divertenti
come si scopre,
sebbene sia divertente pensarci.
In questo caso specifico, ciò che abbiamo è essenzialmente
un esperimento mentale che può essere descritto in
modo abbastanza intuitivo come un gioco.
Le lettere CHSH si riferiscono agli autori, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony e Richard Holt di un articolo del 1969
dove l'esempio
è stato descritto per la prima volta. Non lo descrissero
come un gioco, in realtà, ed è abbastanza comune
riferirsi a questo esempio
non come il gioco CHSH, ma
piuttosto come la disuguaglianza CHSH.
Per un informatico come me, però, è davvero molto naturale
describerlo come un gioco.
Ho già suggerito che
le astrazioni matematiche dei giochi sono sia importanti che utili e ci sono molte diverse
categorie di giochi
WEBVTT
che possono essere considerate. Il gioco CHSH è un
esempio di una classe di giochi chiamati giochi non locali.
Ecco la configurazione in generale
per un gioco non locale.
Abbiamo due giocatori, Alice e Bob, che cooperano come squadra, quindi vincono insieme
o perdono insieme.
Questo significa che non hanno
alcun incentivo ad agire in modo egoistico, quindi è essenzialmente il polo opposto
ai giochi a somma zero,
che sono puramente competitivi, qui il gioco è puramente cooperativo.
C'è una terza entità chiamata l'arbitro.
L'arbitro non è un giocatore nel gioco, ma piuttosto l'arbitro
gestisce il gioco, e in effetti puoi pensare alla specifica
di una particolare istanza
di un gioco non locale e alla specifica di un
arbitro come equivalenti.
C'è un vincolo fondamentalmente importante posto su Alice e Bob, ovvero che una volta iniziato il gioco, è loro vietato comunicare tra loro.
Possono concordare in anticipo
su qualsiasi strategia scelgano, ma nessuna comunicazione
è consentita tra loro durante il gioco stesso.
Se vuoi, puoi immaginare
che il gioco si svolga in una struttura protetta di qualche tipo, come se l'arbitro stesse interpretando
il ruolo di un detective
e Alice e Bob siano sospettati in stanze diverse
di un commissariato, ma un altro modo di
pensare alla configurazione
è che Alice e Bob siano
separati da una vasta distanza e la comunicazione è proibita perché la velocità della luce
non consente la comunicazione
abbastanza velocemente. Se Alice cercasse di inviare un
messaggio a Bob, per esempio, il gioco sarebbe finito nel
momento in cui Bob lo riceve.
Il modo in cui funziona un gioco non locale
è che prima l'arbitro fa una domanda sia
ad Alice che a Bob.
La domanda di Alice è etichettata X e la domanda di Bob è etichettata Y.
In generale, puoi pensare a X e Y come a stati classici
da qualsiasi stato classico tu voglia e nel
caso specifico del gioco CHSH,
X e Y sono bit.
Alice e Bob devono poi fornire risposte; la risposta di Alice è etichettata A,
e la risposta di Bob è etichettata B,
e ancora, queste risposte possono essere viste come stati classici in generale e come le domande, saranno
bit nel gioco CHSH.
A questo punto,
l'arbitro prende una decisione; Alice e Bob vincono o perdono a seconda che
la coppia di risposte A, B
sia giudicata corretta per
la coppia di domande X, Y che l'arbitro ha posto, e dirò ancora un po' di più
su questo tra un momento.
Prima, diamo un'occhiata più da vicino all'arbitro per capire cosa sia
potenzialmente difficile per Alice e Bob in un gioco non locale.
E ciò che rende
potenzialmente difficile un gioco non locale è che l'arbitro può usare la casualità per scegliere le domande X e Y.
Ciò significa che Alice
e Bob hanno incertezza, non sanno in anticipo quale domanda riceveranno, e forse ancora più importante,
non sanno quale domanda
ha ricevuto l'altro e quella incertezza
insieme al fatto che non possono comunicare
è ciò che presenta la sfida.
Quindi, è simile alla situazione in cui un detective
interroga due sospettati in stanze diverse; se
i sospettati non sanno
quali domande vengono poste all'altro, è molto più difficile se sono colpevoli mantenere la loro versione dei fatti.
Ora, ho menzionato poco
fa che l'arbitro prende una determinazione
che Alice e Bob abbiano risposto
correttamente o incorrettamente
a seconda delle domande
che sono state loro poste.
Si assume che questa
determinazione sia fatta secondo una regola fissa
e puoi considerare qualsiasi regola tu voglia,
ma qualunque essa sia,
si assume che Alice
e Bob conoscano la regola, quindi almeno hanno una
possibilità di rispondere correttamente.
Daremo un'occhiata alla
regola per il gioco CHSH tra un momento, ma potremmo
considerare una regola diversa e avremmo un
esempio diverso di gioco non locale.
Alcuni giochi non locali sono interessanti e in effetti alcuni sono davvero affascinanti e misteriosi ancora oggi, e
alcuni non sono così interessanti,
è la natura del
modello dei giochi non locali.
In ogni caso, queste sono le due diverse cose necessarie per descrivere un arbitro: come esattamente vengono scelte le domande
e quali coppie di risposte sono corrette per ogni possibile coppia di domande.
Se abbiamo una descrizione
di queste due cose, allora abbiamo una descrizione per l'arbitro e ciò descrive effettivamente
un'istanza di un gioco non locale.
Ora diamo un'occhiata
al gioco CHSH nello specifico.
Il modo in cui il gioco è
definito o, equivalentemente, come è definito l'arbitro è il seguente:
prima, come ho già menzionato, le domande e le risposte sono tutte bit, quindi l'arbitro invia un bit X
ad Alice e un bit Y a Bob,
e ognuno risponde con un bit. Alice risponde con A
e Bob risponde con B.
Il modo in cui l'arbitro sceglie
quali domande porre è semplice, le sceglie
uniformemente a caso,
quindi, la coppia di domande X, Y ha uguale probabilità di essere una qualsiasi
delle quattro possibilità: zero, zero; zero, uno;
uno, zero; e uno, uno.
Infine, la regola che
determina quali risposte vincono e quali perdono è
che una coppia di risposte A, B è corretta per la coppia di domande X, Y
WEBVTT
se e solo se lo XOR di A e B è uguale all'AND logico di X e Y.
Potrebbe essere un po' più facile da digerire se esprimiamo quelle condizioni
nella forma di una tabella come vedi qui.
Nella prima colonna, abbiamo le quattro possibili coppie di domande, e nella seconda colonna abbiamo le condizioni su A e B
richieste perché
Alice e Bob vincano.
Nei primi tre casi,
l'AND di X e Y è zero, quindi lo XOR deve essere uguale a zero
affinché vincano,
e questo equivale a dire che A e B devono essere uguali poiché A e B sono bit,
e nel quarto caso,
l'AND di X e Y è uguale
a uno e quindi lo XOR di A e B deve essere uguale a uno affinché Alice e Bob vincano
e questo equivale
a dire che A e B devono essere diversi.
Questo è dunque il gioco CHSH, e ora possiamo pensare a
diverse strategie possibili per Alice e Bob e a quanto bene possono fare in questo gioco.
Iniziamo pensando alle
strategie deterministiche in cui la risposta A di Alice è una
funzione della domanda X che riceve, e
allo stesso modo, la risposta B di Bob
è una funzione della
domanda Y che riceve.
E come si scopre, nessuna
strategia deterministica può vincere ogni volta.
Un modo per ragionare su questo è
semplicemente esaminare una per una tutte le possibili
strategie deterministiche e verificare che ognuna di esse perda
per almeno una delle quattro
possibili coppie di domande.
Alice e Bob, ognuno ha
quattro possibili funzioni tra cui scegliere, le abbiamo viste
nella lezione uno, quindi ci sono 16 possibilità
da verificare in totale.
Un altro modo per vederlo è di
pensare alle equazioni qui sullo schermo; stiamo pensando
a strategie deterministiche
dove A e B sono funzioni
rispettivamente di X e Y.
Quindi, per esempio, A di zero
rappresenta la risposta di Alice quando la sua domanda X è uguale a zero e A di uno rappresenta la risposta di Alice
quando la sua domanda X è uguale a uno.
Queste sono le quattro equazioni
che devono essere vere affinché le condizioni di vittoria
siano soddisfatte in ciascuno dei quattro casi.
Per esempio, se X è uguale a
zero e Y è uguale a zero, allora lo XOR di A
e B deve essere uguale a zero,
mentre nel caso in cui X è uguale a uno e Y è uguale a uno, lo
XOR di A e B deve essere uguale a uno.
Un modo per vedere che
non è possibile scegliere le funzioni A e B in modo che
queste equazioni siano tutte vere, è semplicemente prendere lo XOR
di tutte le equazioni.
Lo XOR di qualsiasi
valore binario con se stesso è uguale a zero, e quindi segue che lo XOR
dei lati sinistri
è uguale a zero, questo
perché abbiamo due istanze di A zero, due istanze di A uno,
due istanze di B zero
e due istanze di B uno.
Quindi, facendo lo XOR di tutto insieme
otteniamo il risultato finale di zero, ma se prendiamo lo XOR dei lati destri delle equazioni,
otteniamo uno, non zero. Quindi le quattro equazioni
non possono essere tutte vere, almeno una di esse deve essere falsa
e ciò porterà a una
perdita per Alice e Bob in almeno uno dei quattro casi.
E quindi segue, poiché l'arbitro sceglie le domande
uniformemente, che la probabilità che Alice e Bob vincano
usando una strategia deterministica
è al massimo tre quarti o 75%.
Il fatto che Alice e Bob possano vincere con probabilità tre quarti è in realtà abbastanza facile da vedere;
se Alice e Bob rispondono entrambi sempre zero, per esempio,
avranno ragione tre
volte su quattro.
Quindi Alice e Bob non possono fare
meglio che vincere il 75% delle volte usando una
strategia deterministica.
Ma che dire di una strategia probabilistica?
Ebbene, si scopre che usare
una strategia probabilistica non può aiutarli affatto, perché ogni
strategia probabilistica
può in alternativa essere vista
come una selezione casuale di una strategia deterministica, proprio come le operazioni
probabilistiche possono essere viste
come selezioni casuali di
operazioni deterministiche, come abbiamo visto nella prima lezione.
La media non è mai
più grande del massimo, quindi segue che una
strategia probabilistica non offre alcun vantaggio
in termini di vittoria
rispetto a una strategia deterministica. Questo include anche la possibilità che le scelte casuali di Alice e Bob siano correlate.
Quindi, la conclusione è che vincere con probabilità tre quarti è il meglio che Alice
e Bob possono fare usando qualsiasi strategia classica,
che sia deterministica
o probabilistica.
La domanda naturale da fare a questo punto è se Alice e Bob possono fare meglio usando una strategia quantistica,
e in particolare
se condividono uno stato quantistico entangled che avrebbero potuto preparare
prima di giocare, può essere d'aiuto?
La risposta è sì, può, ed è questo il punto dell'esempio e per questo è così interessante.
Quindi vediamo esattamente come
Alice e Bob possono fare meglio in questo gioco usando l'entanglement.
WEBVTT
La prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è definire un vettore di stato quantistico Chi
theta per ogni angolo theta, come puoi vedere qui sullo schermo.
Quindi, Chi theta è uguale a
coseno theta moltiplicato ket zero più seno theta moltiplicato ket
uno, e qui tra l'altro,
stiamo pensando agli
angoli in termini di radianti.
Quindi, ad esempio, ecco il vettore che otteniamo quando theta è uguale a pi greco
diviso quattro, che corrisponde a 45 gradi.
Il coseno di pi greco diviso quattro
e il seno di pi greco diviso quattro sono entrambi uguali a uno diviso
la radice quadrata di due, quindi questo è solo un altro
nome per lo stato plus.
Ecco un altro esempio quando theta è uguale a tre volte pi greco diviso otto, e nel caso in cui
non ti ricordi il seno
e il coseno di tre volte pi greco diviso otto a memoria,
ecco una tabella di seni e coseni di cui avremo effettivamente bisogno
nel corso di questo esempio
e include quelli di cui abbiamo bisogno per questo particolare vettore.
Ora, se vogliamo prendere il prodotto scalare tra due qualsiasi di questi vettori
per angoli, diciamo alpha e beta, è
semplice farlo.
In questi vettori abbiamo solo
componenti reali, quindi non ci sono
coniugati complessi di cui preoccuparci e otteniamo il prodotto dei coseni
più il prodotto dei seni, e possiamo usare una delle
cosiddette formule di addizione degli angoli
per semplificare, ovvero il
coseno della differenza tra gli angoli e
perché la funzione coseno
è simmetrica intorno a zero,
non importa in realtà in quale ordine li prendiamo.
Se non hai queste identità
trigonometriche memorizzate,
tra l'altro, non sei solo, ma non devi ricordarle,
puoi semplicemente cercarle. Questa ha senso
però quando si pensa all'interpretazione geometrica
del prodotto scalare
tra vettori unitari reali come il coseno dell'angolo tra loro.
Se calcoliamo il prodotto scalare
del prodotto tensoriale di due qualsiasi di questi vettori
con lo stato Phi plus, otteniamo un'espressione simile
eccetto che c'è una radice quadrata
di due al denominatore.
Questa è la prima volta
che lo stato Phi plus compare nel contesto
di questo esempio tra l'altro, e vedremo esattamente perché siamo interessati
a questo particolare prodotto scalare tra poco, ma per il momento
osserviamo solo che otteniamo la stessa espressione che avevamo
per il prodotto scalare diviso
per la radice quadrata di due e quindi possiamo semplificare come prima.
Quindi, definiremo una
matrice unitaria, U theta, per ogni angolo theta
come vedi qui,
non è difficile
verificare che questa sia effettivamente una matrice unitaria.
La cosa fondamentale da
riconoscere è che il vettore si theta è ortogonale al
vettore si theta più pi greco diviso due, e ciò ha senso
perché se ruotiamo di pi greco diviso due, che corrisponde a 90 gradi, otteniamo
un vettore ortogonale.
Se poi moltiplichiamo U
theta per U theta dagger, otteniamo la matrice identità.
Parlando intuitivamente,
ciò che questa matrice fa come operazione è mappare
si theta in ket zero e si theta più pi greco diviso due in ket uno.
A questo punto, abbiamo
tutto il necessario per descrivere la strategia di Alice e Bob.
Prima, proprio come per il teletrasporto e la codifica superdensa, Alice e Bob inizieranno condividendo un e-bit.
Alice tiene un qubit A,
Bob tiene un qubit B, e insieme i due qubit
si trovano nello stato Phi plus.
Le azioni di Alice sono le seguenti: guarda il bit X che
riceve dall'arbitro,
e se X è uguale a zero,
esegue U zero su A, che capita di essere
la stessa cosa di non fare nulla perché U zero è la matrice identità,
se X è uguale a uno, invece, applica U pi greco diviso quattro ad A.
Dopo aver applicato una
delle due operazioni, misura A usando una
misurazione della base standard e invia qualsiasi risultato
ottenga all'arbitro.
Bob fa qualcosa di molto simile, il suo qubit si chiama B ovviamente, e riceve Y dall'arbitro invece di X
ma la differenza fondamentale è
che usa angoli diversi per le sue operazioni unitarie.
Se Y è uguale a zero, applica
U pi greco diviso otto, e se Y è uguale a uno, applica U meno pi greco diviso otto.
E vedremo presto perché queste scelte di angoli sono buone scelte,
non è affatto ovvio.
Ed ecco un diagramma a circuit
che esprime questa strategia.
Bob è in cima e Alice
è in fondo questa volta; ecco l'e-bit che arriva
e questi sono i gate unitari
che Alice e Bob potrebbero o meno applicare
a seconda di X e Y.
Per questo e per questo, abbiamo gate che vengono controllati dal bit X o dal bit Y
e per questi due qui, abbiamo quello che sembra
quasi un gate di controllo eccetto che il cerchio non è riempito.
E questo significa
che se il bit di controllo è impostato a zero, allora il gate viene eseguito e se il controllo è impostato a
uno, allora non succede nulla.
Quindi, è come un
gate di controllo ordinario eccetto che i ruoli di zero e uno per il controllo sono scambiati.
Quindi, effettivamente, Bob
esegue questo gate qui se Y è uguale a zero, esegue questo gate qui
WEBVTT
se Y è uguale a uno, e allo stesso modo, Alice esegue questo gate qui
se X è uguale a zero, e questo gate qui,
se X è uguale a uno.
Quindi, questa è la strategia di Alice e Bob e ora dobbiamo solo
capire quanto bene funziona.
Per l'analisi della strategia quantistica che ho appena descritto, abbiamo
davvero bisogno solo di due cose a questo punto: prima, la
matrice unitaria U Theta
è come vedi qui, e
in secondo luogo avevamo questa formula.
In realtà non abbiamo nemmeno più bisogno della definizione del vettore si theta, queste due equazioni sono tutto ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Ci sono quattro casi da
considerare a partire dal caso uno, ovvero X uguale
a zero e Y uguale a zero.
E se torniamo alla strategia, scopriremo che in questo
caso Alice esegue U zero sul suo qubit e Bob esegue
U pi greco diviso otto sul suo qubit.
Ricorda, Alice è in basso
e Bob è in cima, quindi lo stato che
ottengono è come questo.
E espandendo secondo la definizione di U theta, otteniamo questa
espressione che vedi qui.
Non è necessario espandere
ulteriormente perché abbiamo l'altra
formula in nostro aiuto.
E se applichiamo quella formula
per ciascuno dei quattro termini, otteniamo questo.
A questo punto Alice e Bob misurano entrambi ed ecco una tabella che
spiega la distribuzione dei risultati.
Prendiamo il valore assoluto
al quadrato dei coefficienti per ottenere le probabilità, che capita di essere il
quadrato dei coefficienti
perché i coefficienti sono
tutti numeri reali in questo caso.
Se facciamo uso dei
valori di seno e coseno di prima nella lezione
insieme ad alcune simmetrie, possiamo esprimere queste probabilità
come abbiamo qui
nell'ultima colonna.
Ora, ciò che ci interessa davvero
è la probabilità che vincano, e ricorda che, nel caso in cui X e Y siano entrambi zero,
vincono se A e B sono uguali e perdono se A e B non sono uguali.
Se calcoliamo quelle probabilità, troviamo che la probabilità
che A e B siano uguali è la somma di questo numero e di quest'altro,
che è uguale a due più
la radice di due il tutto diviso per quattro, che è circa l'85%.
La probabilità che A e B non siano uguali è due meno la radice di due il tutto diviso per quattro, che è naturalmente uno meno la quantità
che abbiamo appena calcolato, quindi
vincono con probabilità di circa l'85% in questo caso.
Ci sono altri tre casi da considerare, ma sono tutti molto simili a questo,
nel caso in cui X sia uguale
a zero e Y sia uguale a uno, Bob applica U meno pi greco diviso otto invece di U pi greco diviso otto,
i valori nelle
formule cambiano un po', ma finiamo con esattamente
le stesse probabilità che avevamo nel caso precedente.
Quando X è uguale a zero e Y è uguale a uno, Alice e Bob vincono ancora
quando A e B sono uguali e quindi abbiamo esattamente la stessa probabilità di vittoria
di prima.
Nel terzo caso, quando X è uguale a uno e Y è uguale a zero, abbiamo una situazione simile, gli angoli sono diversi,
ma hanno esattamente
la stessa relazione reciproca, e in effetti otteniamo esattamente lo
stesso vettore che abbiamo ottenuto nel caso precedente.
Quindi le probabilità sono le stesse e così è la probabilità di vittoria.
L'ultimo caso è un po'
diverso come potremmo aspettarci perché la condizione di vittoria
è diversa in questo caso.
Quando X e Y sono entrambi uguali a uno, Alice e Bob vincono quando
A e B sono diversi.
Il metodo di base è lo stesso, sebbene gli angoli siano diversi; questa volta otteniamo questo vettore qui
e puoi verificarlo eseguendo le necessarie sottrazioni.
Le probabilità cambiano finalmente, e se consultiamo i valori di cui abbiamo bisogno, vediamo che le probabilità hanno effettivamente
scambiato posizione rispetto a prima, quindi questa volta è la probabilità
che A non sia uguale a B che è la maggiore delle due,
ma è una buona cosa perché in questo caso, Alice e Bob vincono quando
A e B non sono uguali.
Quindi ancora una volta, vincono con
probabilità approssimativamente dell'85%.
Dato che vincono in ogni
caso con la stessa probabilità, ovvero due più la radice di due
il tutto diviso per quattro o circa l'85%,
questa è la probabilità
che vincano complessivamente.
È meglio di qualsiasi strategia classica per questo gioco, ed è questo
che lo rende interessante.
Questa capita di essere la
probabilità di vittoria ottimale per qualsiasi strategia quantistica; non
puoi fare meglio di così usando qualsiasi stato entangled.
Questo fatto è noto come disuguaglianza di Tsirelson, è intitolata a Boris
Tsirelson che lo ha dimostrato per primo, e per quanto ne so era
una delle prime persone
a descrivere questo esempio come un gioco. Nel caso in cui l'analisi
che abbiamo appena fatto sembri un po' misteriosa,
è possibile pensarci
geometricamente, il che potrebbe essere utile
per darti una migliore intuizione per la scelta degli angoli.
Nello specifico, se usiamo la
formula che vedi qui, che possiamo facilmente dedurre
dalle espressioni
che abbiamo già trovato per i
prodotti scalari coinvolti, possiamo in alternativa
esprimere le probabilità dei diversi possibili
risultati di misurazione
WEBVTT
nei quattro casi come segue: prima, se X, Y è uguale a zero, zero, queste sono le probabilità
dei vari risultati di misurazione, e devi o ricordare o tornare indietro sull'analisi
che abbiamo appena fatto per concludere usando la nostra formula.
Qui, possiamo vedere i
diversi vettori di stato disegnati come prima, e la codifica a colori è che il blu corrisponde
al risultato zero e il rosso
corrisponde al risultato uno.
Puoi vedere che l'angolo
tra i vettori blu e l'angolo tra i vettori rossi
è relativamente piccolo,
è pi greco diviso otto in entrambi i casi, quindi il coseno è relativamente grande, e ciò significa che la probabilità che i due risultati
siano uguali è relativamente grande.
Nel caso in cui X, Y sia uguale a zero, uno, la situazione è simile; l'angolo tra i vettori dello stesso colore è piccolo,
quindi la probabilità di
risultati uguali è di nuovo relativamente grande.
Il terzo caso è simile, e nel quarto caso
quando X, Y è uguale a uno, uno, accade qualcosa di interessante;
questa volta, solo per il modo in cui
questi vettori sono stati scelti, vediamo che gli angoli tra
i vettori dello stesso colore
sono relativamente grandi, e nello specifico gli angoli sono tre volte
pi greco diviso otto in entrambi i casi.
Ciò significa che la probabilità
che i risultati di misurazione siano uguali è relativamente piccola, ma questo è l'unico caso
in cui Alice e Bob vincono
quando le loro risposte non concordano,
quindi è quello che vogliamo.
Ancora una volta, ecco i vettori: quando X, Y è uguale a zero, zero,
quando X, Y è uguale a zero, uno,
quando X, Y è uguale a uno, zero,
e quando X, Y è uguale a uno, uno.
E forse questa rappresentazione geometrica
è utile per costruire una certa intuizione
su come funziona questa strategia
e perché questi vari angoli sono stati scelti nel modo in cui lo sono stati.
Per concludere la lezione, farò alcune brevi
osservazioni sul gioco CHSH.
Prima di tutto, come ho già menzionato, questo esempio non è sempre
descritto come un gioco.
Nella comunità fisica, ad esempio, è più comune che
l'esempio sia descritto semplicemente come un esperimento piuttosto che come un gioco
e Alice e Bob sono
visti come rivelatori piuttosto che come giocatori.
L'idea di base di un esperimento come questo in cui l'entanglement porta
a risultati statistici incompatibili con
qualsiasi descrizione classica
o più in generale qualsiasi
teoria basata sulle cosiddette variabili nascoste locali,
è dovuta a John Bell, il nominatore degli stati di Bell,
e quindi le persone spesso si riferiscono
a esperimenti di questo tipo come test di Bell.
A volte le persone si riferiscono anche
al teorema di Bell, che può essere formulato in modi diversi, ma sostanzialmente dice
che la meccanica quantistica
non è compatibile con le cosiddette teorie delle variabili nascoste locali.
Il gioco CHSH o la disuguaglianza CHSH è essenzialmente un esempio molto bello e pulito
di un test di Bell,
e puoi pensare
a questo esempio come a una prova o una dimostrazione del teorema di Bell.
La seconda osservazione è che il gioco CHSH ci offre un modo per testare sperimentalmente che la teoria dell'informazione quantistica
è una teoria accurata. Possiamo effettivamente allestire esperimenti che implementano il gioco CHSH,
incluso il tipo di
strategia basata sull'entanglement che ho appena descritto, e
vedere se funziona, e funziona.
Questo ci fornisce un
alto grado di fiducia che l'entanglement sia reale, e a differenza dei modi forse
vaghi o poetici
con cui cerchiamo di
spiegare l'entanglement, il gioco o l'esperimento CHSH
ci dà un modo concreto
e verificabile per osservare l'entanglement.
Se sembra importante,
è perché lo è, e il Premio Nobel per la Fisica del 2022
riconosce esattamente questo.
Il premio è stato assegnato a
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, che è la C in CHSH, e Anton Zeilinger
per esperimenti con fotoni entangled che hanno stabilito la violazione
delle disuguaglianze di Bell, o in altre parole, che
hanno dimostrato che le strategie quantistiche
del tipo che ho descritto funzionano davvero e superano le strategie classiche.
E se sei interessato a
saperne di più su questo argomento, ti incoraggio a guardare
il video sul Teorema di Bell della mia collega Olivia Lanes,
qui sul canale YouTube di Qiskit.
E infine, l'argomento dei
giochi non locali in generale è davvero affascinante, ed è
un'area di ricerca attiva
che mette insieme
fisica, informatica e matematica pura e ci sono ancora molte
domande interessanti
sui giochi non locali che
rimangono senza risposta ancora oggi.
E questa è la fine della lezione quattro, nonché la fine della
unità uno della serie sulle Basi dell'Informazione Quantistica.
La prima lezione ha spiegato
come funziona l'informazione quantistica per sistemi singoli in isolamento, e la seconda lezione ha spiegato
come funziona l'informazione quantistica
per sistemi multipli,
il che emerge abbastanza naturalmente da come funziona per i sistemi singoli.
WEBVTT
La terza lezione ha introdotto
il modello a quantum circuit del calcolo, e nella quarta lezione abbiamo esaminato tre importanti esempi
che illustrano le cose che
possiamo fare con l'entanglement.
Lungo il percorso, abbiamo visto alcuni concetti matematici molto importanti,
inclusi i prodotti tensoriali e i prodotti scalari, e abbiamo osservato
alcune limitazioni fondamentali
dell'informazione quantistica.
Spero che ti unisca a me per
la prossima unità della serie, che riguarderà gli algoritmi quantistici, dove ci concentreremo sulla domanda
di quali vantaggi computazionali
offre l'informazione quantistica.
Arrivederci a presto.